well a national fundraising campaign has
been launched tonight to help ukraine
the disasters emergency committee is
appealing for funds to help people
affected by the conflict we're joined
now to discuss that with david miliband
the president and ceo of the
international rescue committee and jan
agarland general secretary of the
norwegian refugee council very good to
talk to you both gentlemen and i'd like
you both first of all just we need to
pause don't we and reflect on the speed
and scale of what's going on here david
miller banned one million people in a
week
yes the
scale of this is obviously huge it's on
a par with the syria crisis
of uh ten years ago uh six and a half
million refugees in the end from
syria but by
the standards of the syria crisis it
took three months for a million syrians
to flee from their own country it's
taken just a week to hit that number and
of course what's going on in inside
ukraine is even more
challenging than the situation once you
cross the borders because you've shown
throughout the day the pictures of the
bombed out buildings there are civilians
there and there are obviously at least a
million probably more civilians on the
run inside ukraine trying to head for
the kind of safety that you've just
showcased from lev so this really is a
capstone for the modern age of impunity
it shows what happens when the rule of
law becomes optional and when the rights
of civilians
are disregarded by an invading power
yeah nagaland i see you nodding along
there in agreement of course in just on
those numbers a million people equate to
something like two percent of the entire
population of ukraine in eight days
indeed it is uh explosive i was myself
in ukraine last month february
it's traveled up and down what was then
the front line in eastern ukraine
the
let's remember there are millions who
cannot also escape
in the eastern part of the country where
my organization has been most active
there is a lot of elderly people
pensioners retired miners they're widows
they cannot flee they are disabled etc
so what we're calling for is a truce a a
humanitarian force so that we can resume
humanitarian operations so that the
civilian population can get out of
harm's way it will be the only sensible
thing and i understand it was discussed
today
between the envoys of ukraine and russia
well let's uh discuss that more than
david miliband i mean there's a very big
difference as you both know better than
most between
discussing safe corridors and actually
getting them to work implementing them
they were of course tried many times in
syria to let's say not great effect
well i think that we do have a lot of
experience of the denial of humanitarian
aid as well as the bombardment of
civilians and i'm afraid that the syria
example is one example but jan eglin
as well as you derma will know well the
lesson of the 1990s in the former
yugoslavia in europe where siege tactics
were used extensively where
indiscriminate bombing was used
extensively and where the international
system was massively challenged now i've
just been on the zoom core with our team
in poland across the border from ukraine
we are already identifying partner
organizations
both in poland and inside ukraine
there's going to be great strain on the
health system and on pharmaceutical
supplies as well as on the food and
water infrastructure and one lesson that
we do know from the 90s and from the
syria campaign is establishing those
routes for aid early is absolutely key
of course that doesn't uh absolve the
politicians or the politics and the
politics can get in the way as it is
today in other countries around the
world like yemen or ethiopia where
aid is being denied but i think there
are some practical steps that are being
taken by the ngos who are part of this
disasters emergency committee campaign
as well as by the un institutions and
that's absolutely vital if we're to
avoid or help some people avoid the
worst of this because jan is right there
will be lots of people who can't get out
and some people who are injured or even
killed on the way out and we've got to
be concerned about the situation inside
ukraine as well as the european response
across the border and yanagalan what
about the humanitarian colleagues you
have on the ground in great numbers
given the nature of the russian attack
they're in great danger as well
they are and that's why we're calling
for this
truce today this uh boss
directly to the kremlin directly to the
parties i i have 70
colleagues in the norwegian refugee
council on the ground inside of ukraine
but at the moment they are fleeing for
their life they are spending most of the
time in the
in the bomb shelter
we have 40 colleagues in severe donetsk
which is in the east there is too little
attention to these most journalists are
like your good colleagues in the western
ukraine
uh the casualties up are you know
mostly in the east the it's it's
horrific the fighting uh there and there
is also where the
elderly the pensioners the
most disabled are so really we need an
end to this madness we need an end to
the assault on civilian cities we need
horses we need this humanitarian
corridors and we need to do
like david just
mentioned we need then
as we all are setting up operations in
neighboring countries and doing
cross-border relief into ukraine most of
those in need are still in ukraine they
very few 1 million has left another 10
20 million are in harm's way well can i
ask you a bit more though about that the
million that have left and presumably uh
the many hundreds of thousands let's
hope it's not too many more that that
follow and the reception they get david
miller and of course the neighboring
countries mainly eu countries are
dealing with with the brunt of those
numbers and just tell me uh your view on
the reception that they're getting there
the eu announcing that they're going to
have ukrainians will receive residence
permits access to housing healthcare
education and very important when it
comes to being a refugee
the right to enter the labor market do
you think that all european countries
should offer this kind of reception
yes i do i think that the information
that we have
is that europe is stepping up day by day
and it's stepping up better and
better remember
there probably will be millions more i
think that the uh un has estimated up to
five million refugees but the european
continent is 500 million people so let's
bear that in mind as we think about the
logistical and integration challenge
from my point of view it's essential
that every eu country european union
country all 27 of them do offer the same
rights and they've committed to do that
on the way that you've in the way that
you've described however it's also very
important that other european countries
i'm thinking of the uk i'm thinking of
norway i'm thinking of switzerland i
think i'm
absolutely clear that those european
countries need to step up in the same
way and it's a source of enormous
sadness to me that the uk has not yet
joined that european mainstream in
committing that ukrainians whatever
their ties to the country they will be
able to find
safe haven and they will be able to
support themselves through work remember
this is an educated population that are
coming
out and that they will be able to find
services for their families i think it's
very very important that europe shows
not just that it's able to defend itself
but that also it's able to defend its
values and that's vital in this conflict
okay
i've got a last question for you both
because i can't have um people with your
experience on without exploring this
issue and it is of course the best way
to end the suffering is to end the
violence is to end the war and you're
both deeply involved in diplomacy and in
other lives in other careers and young
england i mean of course you were deeply
involved in so many peace processes of
course some notably the the oslo accords
the the historic agreement between
israel and the plo
i mean i mean do you see anything like
that any any way of de-escalating this
fairly soon
it has to be very clear that this can
end tomorrow i mean president putin can
end it tomorrow
if this is not uh
this is not syria with the hundreds of
armed groups or
the congo with
half a thousand armed groups it's two
armies it's an attacking army the
russian army can't end it
and there has to be
another a
big big effort by diplomats
to to get the leaders the russians to
their census then of course we also have
to recognize that it didn't get better
in afghanistan or in syria or in yemen
because it got worse in in ukraine we
also have to be as equally generous to
the
people freeing from there as we are now
to ukraine and there is a is an enormous
outpouring of of sympathy solidarity
with ukraine we welcome that let's also
remember all of the other refugees
fleeing from elsewhere and david
miliband your thoughts on the diplomacy
of course with your experience as
foreign secretary of meeting putin
meeting lavrov seeing them up close and
personal negotiating with them
i mean looking at their mindset now is
there any way of deflecting them from
further extreme violence
derma i don't want to mislead you or
your viewers
president putin spoke to president
macron of france today and the french
readout was that they fear the worst and
frankly i fear the worst now as well i
fear a pulverization campaign on the
cities of ukraine i fear for the
civilians of ukraine whether they be in
their bomb shelters or whether they be
on the
on the run and this is now
on a very very dangerous course there is
only one side that can end this and that
is the russian
side but i think it would be giving
false hope to your viewers to pretend
that there's any sign of that at the
moment what we do know
is that there is unprecedented pressure
on the russian system as a result of the
economic sanctions and other
economic interventions that have taken
place and there is unprecedented protest
inside russia as well incredibly brave
uh people but that's where the change is
gonna have to come and it would be wrong
to pretend that there's a diplomatic fix
to get out of that well gentlemen thank
you both so much for sharing your
expertise with this david miliband jan
eggerland very good talking to you thank